migrant apprehensions in november more
than doubling compared to 2020 with over
173
000 encounters but carly despite those
staggering figures democrats still
refusing to back construction of a wall
along the southern border joining us now
to discuss brandon judd national border
patrol council president brandon i feel
like we've had john every month when
these numbers appear and we compare him
to 2020 and it's always higher and it's
always a disaster but despite all that
is it safe to say
we will never see any urgency from
democrats to stop this to build this
wall
no absolutely what they're going to do
is they're going to continue to pander
to their base they want to
appear like they're trying to energize
their base to keep them on board but the
fact remains when you look at what
they're doing they're lying and they're
deflecting when they lie they're talking
about root causes root causes that have
existed for forever for as long as i've
been abort patrol agent and then they
talk they refuse to talk about what's
actually taking place here in the united
states where the root causes exist they
catch and leave program and then when
they deflect their they blame president
trump for everything that's going on
when in reality president trump gave
them the most secure borders that ever
existed when you look at what they talk
about it's nothing more than rhetoric
they provide no evidence whatsoever when
we can give evidence after evidence
example after example of where walls
have worked in san diego when we built
walls it dropped illegal immigration by
80 percent el paso dropped it by 85
percent tucson it dropped it by 75
percent every single place that we've
built walls it's worked that's the
evidence yet the democrats refused to
provide evidence to the american public
the dea says that the agency has seized
more than 15
000 pounds of fentanyl this year alone
that's enough fentanyl to kill every
person in the country hugely important
issue how do you fix the problem
you can't fix it unless you're willing
to address border security
at the root level if you look at
everything that's going on if you look
at the cartels and you look at the way
the cartels are able to bring people in
with impunity and create gaps in our
coverage dea is always going to be
apprehending that fentanyl we need to be
getting it at the at the border not in
our inner cities not in our suburbs not
in our rural areas if we don't stop it
at the border it's going to kill more of
our our us citizens but that's not going
to happen until we take politics out of
border security until we take politics
out of all law enforcement throughout
the entire united states why aren't the
apps the social media apps doing more to
cut down on this i mean this is
happening because it's more or less
being facilitated on these apps
aren't they in trouble for doing this
you would think that the doj but again i
you you've got to look at who's running
everything right now the department of
justice is supposed to be independent
from the white house yet if they don't
do exactly what the white house wants
them to do people are going to lose jobs
that's why the department of justice
doesn't go out and go after
all of these different apps the
democrats are in bed with large tech and
large tech is running these apps they're
able to make money the large tech
doesn't care about the the lowly united
states citizen if you will they care
about the bottom line they care about
how much money they're they're able to
make and that's why the doj just simply
does not go after the large tech and all
of these apps that are able to advertise
all of their services which are illegal
services and it's killing our children
operation lone star let's talk about
that it sends
members of the national guard to the
border to secure it because border
patrol is stretched so thin
and now there are 10 civil rights
organizations who are including the aclu
of texas who are asking the doj to
investigate the program because they say
it's unlawful and racist and xenophobic
what is your reaction to this ask from
the aclu of texas and these other civil
rights organizations
it's so upsetting to me because this is
nothing more than political theater if
you go across the border i was just in
yuma on monday and in yuma i saw several
groups of people that were crossing the
border illegally that they're whiter
than i am this is
these what texas is doing is texas is
going after people equally it's people
that are violating um trespassing laws
it's people that are violating traffic
laws they're not enforcing immigration
laws they can't enforce immigration laws
nor do i
advocate for them enforcing immigration
laws but what they are enforcing is
they're enforcing the laws of their
state which they're allowed to do that
because this is political theater
everybody knows that this lawsuit is
going to be thrown out it's not going to
go anywhere but the aclu wants to appear
like they're doing something when in
reality all they're doing is is uh
pushing the courts and and stalking the
courts with with cases that they don't
need to be here and brandon to your
point this texas operation is very
narrowly tailored under the law they are
allowed to do what they're doing it is
not infringing on federal immigration
law there's no chance that they lose in
court but you're right they're bringing
it just to get all the attention brendan
judd we appreciate your time this
morning thank you sir